Dominique Wilkins hall-of-famer the
Atlanta Hawks vice-president of
basketball and a special advisor to the
CEO Nick joins us on the program Nick
thanks for joining us when's the last
time you dunked well I say um you know
people ask me like I'm kind of still
document of course I can but only
problem is only on Fridays I need a
weakness when you got that nickname the
human highlight film you were in high
school I was in 11th grade and a guy
named Howard Garfinkel gave me that
nickname at 5 star basketball camp up in
Homestead Pennsylvania and what did you
think about that nickname well you know
it was funny because you know I got that
nickname and also a game I scored 42 in
the all-star game
and my game would kind of unorthodox and
so they couldn't tell how it's going so
big long story short they say you know
what we just gonna call him the human
highlight film and I hated the name but
as I got older I like wait a minute hold
on I can make a little money off this
name so it struck you won the slam dunk
contest twice right and then you you
lost out your famously lost out to
Michael Jordan in 1985 does that does
that bother you still bother you no it
doesn't you know what I look at it like
this you know is the fact that they
talking about it 32 years later he was
no it's a great song contest ever you
know and we are forever joined at the
hip but no matter who won the fans got
their money's worth but knew I thought
did I think I want I absolutely I did
but Nick if that was in Atlanta who
would have won that dunk contest you
were Jordan ball out of 100 you know
enjoy that this is the first time in 32
years he and I even mention a dunk
contest each other we've never talked
about it when did you talk to him
this weekend so what did you say does he
acknowledge that you won that Niek yeah
he did like you know we know we were we
were at lunch we're sitting there at the
hotel and and the NICU one you know I
said okay you know
cool so we'll give me the check the
beginning man :
you don't want the trophy you don't care
about that you want to check the check
man and then you lost to your teammates
spud Webb and the following year
uh yeah in Dallas you know it was a real
sentimental thing yeah but you know
smoke was great he was great he really
was but you know I probably won four but
I got credit for two but it's all good
what advice would you give Aaron Gordon
you know it's tough when you lose to
conquer contests that you should
probably should have won and I thank you
you should have won both of those
it's hard for him to come back I know it
is you know because you know he's taking
his mind okay what else I got to do to
win and so for him and he just lost on
the comments you kind of only deter him
for one to do it again who do you think
won the dunk contest um I would say
going what he definitely won yeah I like
how people say well he didn't really
jump over taco fall he still jumped over
let's say tacos 7-5 7-5 are you kidding
me anyway I stood next to taco the other
night and I'm like holy this kid is long
and the fact you went over this guy and
I grabbed a doctor man and that that's
almost impossible did you imagine
dunking over Mark Eaton I wouldn't have
tried i'ma win the truck I mean you know
first of all you know I looked at the
accident waiting to happen
and so I wouldn't write it but the fact
that he attempted it and and and he was
successful and completing that dunk it's
pretty amazing I don't know what they
were looking at every time I have Doc
Rivers on I always make him tell me a
Larry Bird story you've got a Larry Bird
story
there's a few some I can't tell it's
like an you know I you know Larry Larry
was a unbelievable competitor and I love
I remember first I've ever played
against him in the Boston Garden I'm a
rookie and I go shake his hand he takes
his hands and put behind his back and no
way I'm like oh okay well maybe he just
get into the game first was a game you'd
say you own him long in his league and
he hits a hits of three and all right
okay and he did it again on the second
time down so this time I'm pissed off
and so I'm coming down the wing he's
back felon and they pinch the balls for
me
and I jumped and he jumped and I said I
got him
and I dunked and on he fouled me and I'm
pointing in oh I'm talking crap and he
said look at what he said like you you
get it you say you got got heart he
didn't say that's a one you got balls
right that's what he said yeah but I'm
still getting 40 million night I still I
still love that you were on the court I
think meek when when bird went off in
New Orleans against you guys when cliff
Levingston and Antoine Carr got scolded
by Mike fratello it's still one of my
favorite videos those guys were it felt
like they were rooting for bird again
our own team you know what I made sure
of those guys older was got fined $3,000
for the heck really oh yeah oh I was mad
you know you know could we both had a
great game he had a super game and he
was so hot to shoot threes with his left
is amazing it's an amazing play but the
trash talk that went on back then
okay like we never heard it but now we
hear about it who was the best trash
talker
no bird talk trash but no you know he
wasn't one of those I've got to talk to
all the time he just tried to get into
your head but the guy who talked to most
trash was truck person who the
woman he never showed up what would he
say never shut up we just be talking
random stuff oh you know I'm the one
game we played against other and I had
like I think I had 42 and I've been
getting into the third and he said to me
you ain't going no more tonight I'm
locking you down you ain't all that I'm
like son I got one more I'm tired of
kicking your ass I I still think you're
one of the best in game dunkers of all
time Shawn Kemp is up there too who else
would you put in that category of
actually doing it in competition you
know yeah you know it starts with the
granddaddy of his own that's dr. J yeah
man he was he was something in game I
thank God that nobody ever talks about
or talks about David Thompson yeah we
just didn't get this he missed the TV
era niek you know he did he did he did
and he might have had the best vertical
I ever saw I oh my god
when I was in car I'm in high school
when the north come on say I used to go
to the practice up at NC State and I
used to see him cut the ball with his
left and jump up and punch it through
the basket what is right here I'll never
forget that
he doesn't look incredible leaper I've
ever seen yeah that's you know of course
you got Michael Jordan you got Vince
Carter I mean I'm the greatest end game
of dunkers that I've seen if I said you
could create your ultimate slam dunk
contest you and three others who do you
want of course Michael the doctor Vince
that'd be pretty good contest yes it
would now you were a great to standstill
jumper how good were you at you know dr.
J could take off in a foul line
you know Michael was one of those guys
now and granted you guys could all you
know jump off to two legs but that
seemed to be where you were most
explosive why was that as always you're
always more explosive going off the two
because you have more control even if
you get hit in the air
still able to finish the plate a lot of
time you call for one I mean you're
still explosive but if you get hit just
a little is throw you in froze you off
but I've started out as a one foot
jumper you know my me I could go from
the free-throw line and all that stuff
but I started jumping off for to land it
cannon it happened by accident in a game
and it was against Milwaukee against Bob
Lanier along the baseline and I just
started using you know going on for two
feet more you know as my career went on
what's the best poster you ever created
with one of your dunks no man that's a
girl when I'm probably one against
Robert Parish you know after a pitch
from spud and no Mustang was going
through the rack Hall and I was trying
to throw it down the card as I could on
big guys so I think that Bob Lanier long
the baseline when I double pumped her
back was in current to come back around
he's going down I'm still going up you
know so you know it's quite a few it's
hard to say one was better than the
other but it was some it was some great
moments what advice would you give Zion
Williamson you know what it knows I am
is a freak athlete and he really adds
man to a guy his size they do some stuff
he does is pretty amazing the thing I
would tell him his desk continue to grow
as a individual as far as developing
your game inside and out to make his
game more well-rounded but know it guys
got about 20 years old he got all the
time in the world to develop but I
wonder what kind of player you would be
today would you have to develop a
three-point shot Nick I had a good
that's the thing that people don't
realize when they you have to but my
game was the first thing they look at
dunking yeah I may add this two dunks
game I had games where I had 40 plus
game only have one or two dunks in whole
game
I've always to shoot the ball from the
perimeter you know I shot two three I
made more than 500 trees in my career
but the three-point shot wasn't
important me I only used it if I needed
it but yeah
was a mid-range nightmare for guys they
I mean they could garden in the
mid-range you know but I could always
shoot the three so you asked me what
would I do in this air yeah I don't know
but it would be over 35 but I wonder
though some of these like how many
threes would bird have shot per game
because back then like your first half
of his career you know these guys are
shooting maybe two or three at the most
because it wasn't considered good
basketball well you know what if you
took up three it was fine if you took
two threes it was fine but if you miss
your third or four three coach was
putting somebody else in the game you
know because it would consider you know
a bad shot if you continue to take bad
shots you know it put something in the
air put another guy in the game Trey
Young is pretty special you get to see
him on a nightly basis who does he
remind you of
I love true love true and a little guy
was so much heart a lot of toughness he
got for a small guy please you know
people talk about his going but the most
impressive part about his game to me
this is core vision and ability to make
people around him better with his family
the kick and freaking pass special
player did you see him nutmeg James
Harden in the all-star game where he put
it between his legs Nate he's been doing
that all year I know that against James
Harden and that like I don't know that
the other guys it feels like they're
just random but James Harden is like
whoa oh he just did that to James Harden
hey he doesn't know one thing about race
he has an advantage he think he can if
he can use his skill to get by you with
some of his tricky dribbling passing the
kid is amazing I mean I brought that
kids I mean it's this is this great I
mean have chances he and I talk a lot
every day before every game and it's
just special you know if I have Jordan
on I'll ask him about that lunch he had
with you he'll deny that he told you you
won that Sam done contest well we we
know we we were kidding each other and
yeah you know you probably and I say you
know what Mike and I sold them I say you
know man the fact that we still talking
about this stuff unless you know it's
great is right
he said absolutely yeah pretty good
stuff hey great to talk to unique we
appreciate your time would you you just
turned 60 it's kind of hard to roll off
my tongue
[Laughter]
your if you're still dunking at 16 eek
you're doing okay yeah yeah I like to
say that I can I'm still dog you know
what there's only one a little fingertip
dogs you know it's just great thanks for
spending time Nick we appreciate it
no problem guys thank you add Dominique
Wilkins former NBA all-star for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]